[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the guests of honor
the class of 1994
[Music]
the corporation and the faculty of the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
are now declared convened together with
this assembly on this glorious morning
in Cambridge on the occasion of the
commencement exercises of the Institute
for the conferring of its degrees the
stage assembly and audience will please
rise and join professor Ellen Harris
associate provost for the Arts and the
singing of one verse of the
star-spangled banner' to be followed by
the invocation by the Reverend Scott
paradise
can you see its mass leaving whose broad
stripes and bright stars were so
gallantly streaming
[Music]
let us pray oh holy God creator of all
things we offer thanks with hearts
overflowing for the privilege to live
and work in this place for the
opportunity to learn for the experiences
of testing which try us as silver is
tried for friends and mentors for the
excitement of ideas the joy of discovery
well God of justice and love we find the
world shaped not only by human
achievements but also by human failures
we have ended the Cold War and reduced
the nuclear threat but we see violence
proliferate in families on the streets
in oppressive regimes and in civil wars
around the globe we have created great
wealth but we have acquiesced to great
poverty we have awakened as a nation to
the environmental crisis but we have
been unwilling to make the changes
necessary to resolve it
Oh God giver of life and hope we commit
ourselves to renewed sense of vocation
may we realize that even the smallest
deeds of love and justice and generosity
can change history
may we learn to risk speaking the truth
when evil is being done and all are
silent may we work less and the problems
of the powerful and the prosperous and
more on the needs of the poorest the
weakest and the most vulnerable of our
brothers and sisters may we together
blaze a path toward a world at peace
with itself and reconciled with the
earth Oh God
our companion on the way be with us as
we go forth from this place give us hope
for the future and joy in our hearts
amen
please be seated
I'm pleased to welcome to the platform
this morning
the Honorable Kenneth E Reeves mayor of
the city of Cambridge it is my privilege
to welcome His Highness the Agha Khan
spiritual leader of the shia is Mali
Muslims his Hut His Highness the Agha
Khan will now present the address
[Applause]
president vest members of the
cooperation of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology distinguished
members of the faculty mayor Reeves
happy graduates even happier parents and
others gathered here today I am pleased
and honored to be with you this morning
mit has shown a standard of excellence
in education and research that sets a
benchmark for universities everywhere
you have been at the Institute for years
may be excused if you take this in
stride but for me coming here for the
first time in several years the energy
of the place is palpable actually my
reaction is somewhat personal when as a
young man I began to think about
colleges MIT was my first choice in the
end I acceded to the advice of my
grandfather who favored Harvard
in fact I didn't even apply anywhere
other than MIT and MIT accepted me on
the basis of my grades they didn't even
ask me to take an examination which is
good because I could hardly understand
written English when my grandfather told
me I shouldn't enroll here I was
devastated that really put the kibosh on
my plans to study science
you see I learned Harvard English
education has been important to my
family for a long time my forefathers
founded a La Salle University in Cairo
some 1000 years ago at the time in the
Fatimid Caliphate in Egypt discovery of
knowledge was seen by those founders as
an embodiment of religious faith and
faith as reinforced by knowledge of
workings of the creator's physical world
the form of universities has changed
over those 1000 years but that
reciprocity between faith and knowledge
remains a source of strength mit has
changed also over its 130 years this
university was initially designed to
meet the needs of society in a newly
industrialized world as the world and
its needs evolved so has MIT is
curriculum steadily the emphasis on
social sciences and humanities has
expanded as the Institute has recognized
increasingly that the range of
technologies that are needed to solve
societal problems goes far beyond
those of engineering and Natural
Sciences the increased richness of
Education results in an increasingly
versatile set of graduates as I look out
over those today who are here I see that
MIT has changed in other ways the great
continents of the world are now
represented in your student body and in
your faculty so two other great
religions of the world mit seems
prepared to take advantage of excellence
from all quarters the fact that is sure
to reinforce the Institute's future
strength when I was thinking about the
theme that I should choose for this talk
I considered first that commencements
are occasions to reflect on general
truths truths that will retain their
validity over the course of your lives
and over the wide range of intellectual
interests that you graduates embody but
how is that search for generality to be
squared with the very particular point
in time that today represents you and I
are here in a real sense only because
1994 finds MIT in the world at
distinctive stages other evolution still
the particular can provide insight into
the general so my comments today will
draw on the particular in the hope of
saying something of value about the
general I shall talk today about
encounters encounters when two people
meet
or to particles or to cultures in that
crucial moment of interaction the
results of an encounter are determined
in the simplest of encounters say with
two billiard balls the outcome is a
predictable result of position velocity
and mass but the encounters that
interest me most are not so simple in
the Encounters of people and cultures
much depends on the path that each has
taken to that point these are not
stochastic processes the subjects have
histories the encounter has complexity
and rich dimensionality the result of an
encounter between two people or between
two cultures is shaped by the
assumptions of each by their respective
goals and perhaps more directly relevant
to a university by the repertoire of
responses that each has learned
encounters therefore have aspects of
both the general and the specific what
makes our current time distinctive are
the new combinations of people and
cultures that are participating in these
encounters to ongoing social and
political changes illustrate the reasons
for these new combinations the first is
the collapse of communism in the USSR
and Eastern Europe you graduates may
feel that you've been at MIT forever but
it really is remarkable that the
overturning of the Communist world has a
since most of you started your studies
here you go out into a world where the
rules are different from those that held
when you entered colonialism is moribund
no longer is it enough to decide whether
one is aligned with communism or
capitalism in a bipolar world now a full
range of complicated choices is opened
up to people in the developed and the
developing world alike a massive break
on change has been released the
potential for creative action creative
encounters is now much enhanced this
change is a work in progress however the
potential of the moment must be seized
four conditions for change may not
always be so propitious there is the
real possibility that the Soviet Union
may reconstitute itself if the social
upheaval that accompanies political
disintegration and economic reform is
allowed to become less tolerable than
the strictures of a totalitarian state
while these shocks reverberate from the
ex communist bloc profound changes of a
very different character are to be found
in the Islamic world here the changes
are in both perception and reality and
both of them are works in progress to
the Islamic world is remarkably poorly
understood by the word by the West
almost
terra incognita even now one sees
pervasive images in the West the
caricature Muslims as either oil sheiks
or unruly fundamentalists the Islamic
world is in fact a rich and changing
tapestry which the West would do well to
understand the economic power of the
Islamic world is increasing not so much
because of Middle Eastern oil but
because of the rapid growth of newly
industrializing countries like Malaysia
and Indonesia its population is
increasing and already represents nearly
one-quarter of the world's total it is
remarkably diverse ethnically
economically politically and it's it in
its interpretations of its own faith the
Muslim world can no longer be thought of
as a subset of the developing world
Islam is well represented in the United
States Canada United Kingdom and Western
Europe and that presence is broing the
religious diversity of Islam is
important and misunderstood by most
non-muslims this is not the forum to go
into the multiple reasons for this
misunderstanding but for many in the
West the first awareness that there were
two major branches of Islam Shia and
Sunni only came with the Iranian
Revolution that represents a
superficiality of understanding that
would be as though we Muslims only just
learned that there were two branches of
Christianity Protestant and Catholic and
had no understanding
of the Reformation the authority of the
church all the ideas that led to the
proliferation of Protestant sects in the
16th and 17th century or as though we
thought that most Americans were Branch
Davidians in the face of such lack of
knowledge about 1/4 of the world's
population one may reasonably ask what
the role of the university is in setting
this straight it seems clear to me that
at the most basic level the university
is responsible for helping its students
to learn not only the simplifying
principles that the various learned
disciplines have found useful in
understanding our world but also the
rich complexity of history and language
and culture that make real-life problems
interesting and difficult MIT now
teaches both of these lessons well and
vigorously but it seems not always to
have done so
indeed I am told that at the opening of
MIT in 1865 one local newspaper reported
with a note of triumph that the creation
of MIT quote sealed the fate of that
system by which our youth waste the best
portion of student life in burrowing
into the grammars and dictionaries
erases less enlightened than their own
unquote mit has clearly come around to
thinking that those less enlightened the
races of something to teach and that
teaching helps the university fulfill
its potential I would argue however that
the university's potential is met not
just in the
the intelligence of its students but
also in bringing them to understand the
importance of engaging themselves in
solving the problems of the world the
great political and social changes
around us are creating opportunities for
service that promise to be deeply
rewarding to persons with the engaged
intelligence to be successful at
important but difficult work let me take
one example to illustrate the
challenging encounters
to which today's graduates might apply
their intelligence Tajikistan is a
mountainous country in Central Asia of
five million people more than 90 percent
Muslim as a republic in the former
Soviet Union bordering China and
Afghanistan it had a strategic
importance that dwarfed its natural
resources the Soviet Union therefore
invested heavily in Tajikistan building
roads and power stations supplementing
food supplies and equipment developing
the educational health systems the
result was a highly educated
sophisticated but largely rural
population that managed its affairs well
at home by the rules of the game at that
time and provided well-developed human
resources for export to other parts of
the Soviet Union with the fall of the
Soviet Union things changed for
Tajikistan subsidies which had provide
provided most the Republic's budget and
for the remoter parts 80% of the food
supply were cut off the result has been
hunger shortages a few
and clothing and deep uncertainty about
the future long suppressed ethnic
tensions between indigenous Tajiks
neighboring us Beck's and Kyrgyz and
immigrant Russians amongst others became
more evident as groups jostled for
political and economic control religion
emerged from private houses where it had
been practiced covertly for sixty years
to become a manifest force Tajikistan
has become the focus of one of the most
interesting encounters of the day it is
here and in other Central Asian
Republics that the three great cultures
encounter each other the Communist world
the Muslim world and the Western world
it is here that those three cultures
could forge a success that would
contrast darkly with the brutal failure
in Bosnia the result of the encounter in
Tajikistan may determine much about the
way history unfolds over the coming
decades so it is worth thinking a bit
about the stance that each of these
cultures might take in preparing for
this encounter that thought might need
one to ask what it would take for this
or any encounter to be constructive I
suggest that there are four
prerequisites for success for each of
the cultures the result should first
draw on its strengths and second be
consistent with its goals
third the result should be a sustainable
improvement in the current situation and
fourth the transition should be humane
each of these three cultures has
something to bring to the solution of
the problems of Tajikistan the West has
many strengths but prominent among them
are science and democracy with their
public mechanisms for self correction
and also private institutions liberal
economics and a recognition of
fundamental human rights the Muslim
world offers deep roots in a system of
values emphasizing service charity a
sense of common responsibility and
denying what it seems to be the false
dichotomy between religious and secular
lives the ex communist world although it
failed economically made important
investments in social welfare with
particular emphasis on the status of
women and was able to achieve in
Tajikistan impressive social cohesion
just how to combine these competencies
to solve Tajikistan's problems is not
clear but if the outcome is to be
sustainable it seems necessary to
concentrate resources on the development
of private institutions of accountable
public institutions and of human
potential
but how to get from here to there
without inflicting cruel damage on the
people already buffeted by shortages and
change again the way is not entirely
clear but one should strive to retain
the powerful ties of mutual support that
in different ways bind individuals
together in Muslim and communist
societies and one should see that the
impressive gains in health and education
are not lost in the transition for it
would be unconscionable to allow for
example the Equality of men and women
that has been achieved in Tajikistan
over the last sixty years to be erased
in the transition to a market economy
these are the prerequisites that I hope
the representatives of these three
important cultures will keep in mind as
they have their own encounter over
Tajikistan
if the encounter of the Muslim world
the West and the ex communist world
takes account of the need for each to
draw on its own strengths to be
consistent with its goals to strive for
a sustainable improved outcome and to
ensure a humane transition then the
encounter will have been as successful
as it is important indeed the importance
of Tajikistan has if anything increased
in recent years as events in neighboring
countries continue to remind us turning
back to today's graduates I hope that
these four prerequisites applied equally
to the encounter that you are just
completing with MIT knowing the quality
of faculty and students here
I have no doubt that the encounter
between you and the faculty has drawn in
your respective strengths I hope each of
you kept consistent with your goals even
as they may have devolved over your time
here the quality and sustainability of
the outcome will be determined over the
course of your lives but reading the
smiles amongst the graduates I judge
that the transition your time at MIT
must have been tolerably humane in
conclusion I would recall the words of
former MIT president James Killian jr.
quote we need better linkages between
science and humanities with the object
of fusing the two into a broad humanism
that rests upon both science and the
liberal arts and that does not weaken
either we need bifocal vision to thread
our way among the problems of modern
society unquote that need to use the
power of complementary academic
disciplines remains true today what is
now clear is the need also to draw on
the wisdom of different cultures in
solving those problems thank you and
please accept my best wishes for a
lifetime of constructive encounters
thank you
[Applause]
your highness thank you very much for
your insightful and challenging comments
on encounters human and cultural and
thank you so much for gracing this
commencement 36 years after you might
have been at another commencement had
your grandfather not intervened
now mr. Carroll brown president of the
graduate student council will give a
salute to MIT from the graduate student
body
following this MS Anne Chen president of
the senior class will present the class
gift to president vest after Ms Chen's
presentation president vest will deliver
his charge to the graduates
Thank You dr. gray in presenting the
graduate students salute to MIT I want
to speak in terms to which students can
most easily relate
I don't watch Star Trek The Next
Generation
so I'll employ another familiar approach
modeled after Dave Letterman's top ten
lists so without further delay the top
five reasons for students to salute MIT
number five
only at MIT can you experience the joy
and thrill of turning in a 200-pound
thesis for a quarter ounce receipt
number four mit supports an approach to
learning and research that is laid-back
relaxed and carefree
number three MIT continually strives to
break down barriers and push limits in
all areas technology science diversity
and tuition cost structures number two
our campus police patrols view lows and
highs of this wonderful campus on which
we work and live and the number one
reason to salute MIT
we are the premier engineering and
science institution in the world not to
mention Sloan is now ranked ahead of
that little business school up the river
graduates when times get tough out there
just remember all the true truly
rewarding experiences and relationships
you have had while MIT they will serve
you well congratulations and good luck
always I remember the last time all of
us the class in 1994 were assembled
together it was in credit aureum during
art of our freshman year former MIT
president Paul Gray told us to look at
the people seated around us he then told
us one out of five of us wouldn't
graduate in four years
you may have been worried that you
wouldn't graduate or you could have been
wondering which one of your friends
wouldn't graduate but I think president
gray made an impression on most of us
today all of us have made it we should
be very proud when we entered MIT we
were a unique class we were supposed to
be the smartest class to enter since we
had the highest SAT average we were the
first to experience pass/fail with C
being passing and not D during our four
years at MIT we witnessed many changes
MIT became ranked number four in US News
and World Report ahead of both Caltech
and Stanford we felt the disappearance
of a mandatory $1500 meal plan we saw
the emergence of two new sorties and one
new fraternity we face the possibility
of getting rid of AI AP but instead we
lengthened it to a full four weeks once
a fried man turned into two and then for
Vance our meal plan IDs and dorm Keys
merged into Student Services cards we
also observed the Persian Gulf War we
witnessed the abolishment of apartheid
in the election of a South Africa's
first black president we saw the tearing
down of the Berlin Wall we experienced
the breakup of the Soviet
Union all of these changes suggest that
change is good and that changes
improvement we all have the ability to
make changes whether globally nationally
or locally and I believe we have a
certain responsibility to make a
difference
our first change as an alumni class is
our senior class gift all of us have
benefited from past alumni class gifts
whether they are renovated classrooms or
financial aid or something else and now
feature classes will benefit from our
gift as a class we have already raised
forty three thousand dollars for MIT I
am pleased to announce that twenty four
percent of our class has participated in
this year senior gift an 87% of those
pledges are over a five-year period the
majority of our classmates have chosen
to have their gift help fund the senior
project which involves renovating and
expanding the Stratton Student Center
information desk and adding to it an
enclosed box office I envisioned the MIT
ticket and information source becoming a
center where the MIT community can track
major Institute community national and
international happenings Duracell
evasion monitor events board and
database in addition students will be
able to pick up important forms reserved
drop poster and Lobby ten space and buy
tickets to MIT events all in the same
place class in nineteen ninety four
graduates we have made a worthwhile
difference thank you
[Applause]
Thank You miss Chen it is a moving
experience to receive for the Institute
a gift from the class and a moment like
this especially when we think about all
we put you through we appreciate it very
much
your gift a new information booth and
the Student Center is certainly fitting
for these times I'm sure your class will
in many ways be racing ahead of most of
us down the emerging information Highway
and we are very grateful for the lift
that this gift will give to all the
students who follow you thank you very
much once again we are assembled in
Killian Court the great court of MIT to
celebrate accomplishment heritage and
passage it may perhaps seem odd that a
community so dedicated to the future so
permeated by scientific objectivity
comes together wearing strange and
colorful medieval regalia but indeed it
is fitting and seemingly fulfilling of
deep human needs that such rituals take
place they remind us of the continuity
through the ages of discovery and
learning of our role in an unbroken
centuries-old chain of human
accomplishment achievements of mind and
of spirit but above all it celebrates
your accomplishments during your student
years this is not to say that you have
accomplished the remarkable feat of
graduating from MIT on your own however
we are surrounded today by parents
family friends spouses and children who
have supported and sustained you through
the years you will recognize them today
by their smiles brought about by their
great pride in your accomplishment and
no doubt by a sense of great relief to
their bank accounts let us then express
our appreciation to all who have come to
Cambridge today to join in this
commencement ceremony
will you the graduates please rise turn
to your audience and give them the
applause they so deeply and richly
deserve it is also especially wonderful
to see the babies and small children who
come to see their mothers and fathers
graduate they too are welcome and as
this ceremony stretches onward I give
each of them special presidential
approval to comment upon the proceedings
at any time and in any manner they see
fit
in delivering this charge my task should
be to set before you great principles by
which to live yet in this age of
relativism as I pondered just which
principles to disclose to you today I
recalled the statement of no grit no
less a great intellect than Groucho Marx
who once said with great conviction
these are my principles and if you don't
like them I've got some other ones so on
second thought I decided I would bypass
the wisdom and just remind you of an
experience that we have shared together
some of you will recall that this class
is also my class on August 30th 1990 we
came together for the first time USM I
t's new freshman class and I as mi t--'s
new freshman president that moment which
Ann referred to a moment ago standing
before 1100 of the brightest and most
creative young men and women from around
this nation and around the world
gathered together in Kresge Auditorium
to begin their education at MIT was
surely one of the most exhilarating of
my life on that day we were all proud to
have been selected to join the ranks of
my tea we shared the exhilaration of
becoming part of its intellectual and
creative atmosphere we were confident
and eager to get on with the year's
activities but to tell the truth we also
were a little apprehensive about the
less certain aspects of what lay ahead
nonetheless we knew that we were all
embarking on the next stage of a great
adventure I said to you that day that I
hoped you would accept me as a member of
your class and trusted that you would
allow me to live and work among you I
also noted that I looked forward to one
other occasion when I would stand before
you in a formal setting and that would
be in Killian Court at your graduation
in the spring of 1994 well we made it
and here we are for all of us these four
years have been intense they seemed to
have passed in the twinkling of an eye
and also to have lasted a lifetime we
moved through changes in our internal
and external world worlds that were
beyond our imagining we encountered new
ideas and new people we were enriched by
what we learned in these encounters
above all we learned to couple
intellectual rigor and discipline with
creativity and innovation and we gained
the self-confidence to approach
virtually any challenge that may lie
ahead and the challenges before us are
great His Highness by his presence here
today and then the thoughts he shared
with us reminded each of us just how
great these challenges are we live and
work in a rapidly changing an
increasingly interdependent world
Society it is a world in which New
Balances must be struck we must resolve
the tensions between competition and
cooperation between fragmentation and
integration between nation and world
this will take some learning we
understand well the value of competition
we know the value of the rugged
individual in the iconoclast but we are
just beginning to learn the value of
cooperation and of teamwork economically
socially politically if you want to
shape a vibrant and just future you must
learn to cooperate as well as to compete
the message of cooperation is simple but
its implementation is not for we seem to
a fragmented along every conceivable
fault line fragmented by intellectual
discipline fragmented by race fragmented
by gender fragmented by geography in the
international arena we have stepped back
at last from the superpower standoff but
we find peace and stability challenged
by the unleashed forces of nationalism
ethnic hatred and local warfare with
every such division we learn more of it
we lose more of a sense of our common
humanity it will not be easy to resolve
our differences in tensions but if we
are to build the future we want for
ourselves and our children we must build
it together we must have a sense of
common purpose we must have an
integrated inclusive view of history we
must have community we must have mutual
respect we must hold common values at
the deepest levels I believe this is
possible because I believe that the true
historical trend is one of communication
interaction and cooperation witness the
people of South Africa who have at last
placed apartheid behind them and set off
on a brave new path I do not suggest
that we sweep aside all differences
quite the contrary we thrive on
differences of Express of experience
culture and perspective as Alfred North
Whitehead said in his 1925 lectures on
science and the modern world
quote other nations of different habits
are not enemies
they are God sins this is true whether
we speak of society's professions or
single institutions
the electrical engineer and the
mechanical engineer are able to build
systems together which neither can build
alone men and women together create a
balanced discourse and worldview black
and white brown and yellow red and tan
create a campus and a nation far more
meaningful and creative than any could
alone as you shape the future you must
respect and cherish differences but you
must build common purpose and values MIT
is an American institution and each of
you as a citizen of some nation for most
of you that nation is the United States
of America but MIT is also an
institution of the world and its
greatness derives in large measure from
its cosmopolitan nature and connections
throughout the world the same must be
true of you be proud and committed to
your Nations but also look beyond them
to shape a future of greatness you must
be citizens of the world and though this
world seems increasingly less
predictable and less stable the
opportunity to discover learn grow and
serve has never been so great I am
optimistic that we and especially you
will make the most of this opportunity
why am i optimistic we know we need only
look around ourselves today our faculty
and our students are the reason for this
confidence and this hope because MIT is
a place that helps to shape the future
because of our faculty MIT is a place
where science advances where art thrives
where technology extends our reach where
thought leads to new order we're new
modes of teaching and learning or
invented and put to use but the still
deeper reason for optimism is you you're
unmatched in your talent your edge
your sense of service your
entrepreneurial spirit and your basic
goodness beyond that you have had the
remarkable experience of living and
learning in a truly international
multicultural community and all the
while you have been setting and meeting
your own highest standards with such a
legacy you give us all great hope for
the future you will not fail us you will
not fail that future men and women of
MIT I wish you Godspeed and the very
best of good fortune
[Applause]
by virtue of the authority delegated to
them by the corporation of the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
and on the recommendation of the faculty
president vest will now present The
Bachelor of Science degrees and the
bachelor and Master of Science degrees
awarded simultaneously and provost
Righton will present advance degrees the
names of the recipients of Bachelor of
Science degrees in bachelor and Master
of Science degrees awarded
simultaneously will be read by the
associate provost for Institute life
Samuel J Kaiser and Dean of
undergraduate education and student
affairs author C Smith the names of the
recipients of the advanced degrees will
be read by the deans of the five schools
the first persons to be recognized are
the class marshals who are seated here
on the stage recognition will now be
given to the officers of the class of
1994 and the president and vice
president of the graduate student
council who are seated on the stage and
chin president of the class of 1994 is
awarded the degree of Bachelor of
Science in biology Catherine L Downard
treasurer of the class of 1994 is
awarded the degree of Bachelor of
Science in aeronautics and Astronautics
[Applause]
karlby Brown president of the Graduate
Student Council is pursuing dual Master
of Science degrees through the leaders
for manufacturing program
Christopher M Gittens vice president of
the Graduate Student Council is entering
the sixth year of graduate study in the
Department of Chemistry he is pursuing
the degree of Doctor of Philosophy
[Applause]
Bachelor of Science diplomas will now be
presented to students in the School of
Architecture and planning who have
completed the specified degree
requirements for Bachelor of Science in
Art and Design Dalia o Ali
[Music]
advanced degree diplomas will now be
presented to students in the School of
Architecture and planning who have
completed the specified degree
requirements
Master of Architecture Darryl e Aldrich
Gregory e Anderson Peter M Brockman jr.
Elizabeth B Aronson James D Christian a
Bruner Kathy why Chang
Stephanie M chain Michael L China Eva a
qu l SW done Mateus tree
Lilly data Ronald J Patricia L Dunlavey
Taylor galleon Eric M field
Daniel Carini Bradley E
Gil ffice jr. Susan e Hollister Noah G
Greenberg Reger e ke Bo she made row
Hernandez
Helen be Jeffrey sue om Julie J Kim
Russell f-con Kristin K leader Michel J
Kim Yelena limber ski sue Oh Kim Lea J
McGavin Marianne Larios Richard K Olsen
Jennifer s Lee Cola G Parker Christine M
McCauley
Lenore a passive auntie Catherine L
nurse turf pole in Richard Victoria L
parson
Pamela W satyr le Erik V Randall sua she
Nevada Jay Rodriguez yon slate Robin L
Stark
Lillian T son Stella be see Christina II
wash Susan II of June P Williamson Sita
even Qatar Oman Angela s wrong also
member of the class of 1994 Executive
Committee Bachelor of Science is
recommended by the Department of
Architecture he had a el Nikesh Master
of Science in architecture studies Raya
H on e4 Bachelor of Science in planning
Dana L Bergdorf also master in city
planning
salvatore or Torino Gail Irene Cheney
Erin jet s Bala Hartley M Khun grace W
Ching Thomas a Lawson jacked about old
jr. the third Nicholas J Pierce si-xiong
thing for Bachelor of Science diplomas
will now be presented to students in the
School of Engineering who have completed
the specified degree requirements for
Bachelor of Science in civil engineering
IRA a beer Stefan us Hannon Clinton s
bench main hull Lynn Stephanie a Brooks
yes'um Nabil Brian C browning Chloe gee
Papa Nastasia Elizabeth W young soo Miah
partha Saffy Eric our Martin
Lawrence s Robert see Mendoza yelling
whoo
Paul M Moody Masaki
yone sue Steven are Samari Oh Andre
hijiki Peter K R approaches Master of
Science in building technology and CNB
Dandridge Michael Jay Williams Michael
Jane McCormack ting chuan whoo
takashi nakamura for a Bachelor of
Science in environmental engineering
science Carrie be Bui Eric M Oliver
Dylan a Bruno
Master in city planning
Lana w ox or Oh Michael M Collins
Monica M Ameren Darryl a fruit Ligia E
Honda Annette see guy Marion s Avalos
Jane M hammer Sarah e Bakken Hillary are
Judas Regina
J Blair Zachary I Johnson Carolyn Brown
Jill see title Sarah elk Alton King Kong
Russell see Klaus Salvador Lopez Cordoba
Patrick Tuohey field
Stephanie martyr Alexander P LaMotta
Jose an held Marcus jr. Michael I
garland Sara M atlas Sofia Hiller drew L
McGilvery James a Jemison Brenda P
Mooney open Bruce a killin
Thomas a Nowak
Carolyn J Kim Karen
J nut Karen M Lord Oh Krystal K rool
Anna Jay Lee Nelly a Rosario
hello not lotsa la s Shalu Josephine K
Louie Gregory V shank any Kayla Quito
Stephanie see slatkin Jacqueline be
Marsh mark T Thompson Rodolfo Mata
Robert a Ullman Margaret a McCoy Sara M
Zion Maria be MIDI Olli Bachelor of
Science as recommended by the Department
of Civil and environmental engineering
Cheston D Buchanan shaman Nia
Carlos be Cashman Elizabeth M more James
are many guinea kala D Morelli Rosa see
Wren Joanne pata Bachelor of Science in
mechanical engineering
Kofi a amanwe Kimberly M tall bear Eric
L Amundsen Hiroko Tanaka
Helen T Ezrin Satoru Veda Walter e-baby
AK Jo Shin Young Laura G Barrett Joe
John Young
John our Bauer Master of Science in
urban studies and planning John Dee
Emeril Robert B Bergen Master of Science
in media arts and sciences MC Dolan
Jason I Peterman mock d Halliday
Jeffrey J Breedlove Roger G commode
James G Brewington LM Kota cos Chad M
Brooks BC Krishna Andrew G Carrillo LNG
turetsky Sally a Chang L&D Witzel Blythe
Dion e Chapman master of science without
specification of field Paul Jay Dworkin
Tina Chen Renji Evans Teresa
teacher Zhu thicker Haider Edward Jay
Chou Manuela a Pereira Lisa each Oh
Junior M vasconcelos Shin Jae choy
doctor of philosophy with all the rights
and privileges pertaining thereto
Barry M Aaron's Terrence why ciao
mark Baldwin Brian J Christensen young w
qi Julian J chun-li Jean gem Brian P
Collins Steven M Drucker Kimberly s
Cornwell shin Wan Lin Adam D Cunningham
Fred G Martin Dolan see dose Michael a
McKenna George see David Rachel King
Wayne our Dempsey
sherry a Wendell Kim Mortensen James s
Dirksen
advanced degree diplomas will now be
presented to students and the number one
school of engineering in the country who
have completed the specified degree
requirements
Master of Science in civil and
environmental engineering Nicholas W
Abood Matthew R Drake Andrew s out of
oak Allen a Duras Darius banaji Khalil
ml sir Duke Jonathan s Brasher Farooq M
allahi Jaime F Brito orchid s key Sheila
G buzzy Abraham s frog Cerio Covarrubias
Fernandes John M feelin the third Thomas
K Davies
Carolyn M fennec Indira idea hey Suz
Michael why thing Carol do vowel Jeremy
M Galland walid K Fakhri Giovanni a
gambrel Yoshihiko fukuchi Stephanie v
Gellar Jose see Galindo Cherith Robert
Iijima tell Gavin Gong Dennis K Goodrem
Moxie Graham Carrie see gum Bert
Nagi a Amaya Tina prominent ela xuxian
hyung Christian D Hamer Elizabeth
Henderson hunts d hope yaki bazooka mark
M height rose Roberto Hynix guns
Sharon s John Denise and Lewin Colleen M
Kaiser Stephan s MacLeod the Joseph H
Carlin Rashid Makati Murray Katara
Saul a new chat le the second
dokyun Kim
Antonio or kuzey Heather L cupboard
Dawid a panderer Union coal donnagon
peer upon John V Lum Judah L Richmond
Paul Jay Lancelot a Marika Katharina
Sant'Agata
Luisa la Penna so he'll cash Shikari
Judith a Luckman Joseph V Sinfield
June be Li each arrows summer August in
jail a on Catherine's Tomales winning
see young Toru Takahashi rayel Luis
Cheech AIDS I hon scared
Lemke takashi washi me Allenby new
Jennifer kwin Christie a Logan Karen I
yes back Geoffrey K ma sha mang whoo
Douglas M McBride Master of Science in
mechanical engineering jeongmok bay
Matthew P Manning Robert S box testin
Michael P Mark Miller Urey are been
Tania Steven J monarch Daniel J
Bronstein
Evan DiMatteo Colin D Chapman John G
McCandless boat yung Chen Neil our meta
Michael a true
Vikram Metro Herbert V Darrow T Emery
Mamaji Joe Lou Christine de robot
Rebecca see Milam also master of science
Shane Imperator Andrew P Millville
Jeffrey P Gardner
Christopher M Minich I'm William a grass
mire Mary Anne Morrow Arlene Guerrero
J a Mahavir swim D Guerrera surrender
nor Dagmar a house ikechukwu oblique a
Travis L Heine Sean M Olson also Master
of Science and us Hytner Alejandro
Padilla
Dana Henry Anna Nanette L Palmer
Sofia T come Scott
Paxton Stephen G Lee guillermo e bechard
Mijares James F misc eldest third Alton
H Phillips Jeffrey a Nielsen Andres
Persian ski also master of science
Isamu or Kimora Jerry e pratt Joseph
keypad or Neelam Jaime P Corrado
Jason why pong mark I Randall John BP v
Catherine C row
Maurice Andre Rekha naughty Gloria M Rho
Michael J Rome Fabrizio e Rodriguez
tsukareta Sahu Michael J Sampson also
master of science John Casey Edward J
Sarnowski Buchwald Sinha Christopher D
Schechter Andre de Smith Rebecca a
scramblin Heather G Smith a DW Shanna
also master of science
Norman son tarik M shoka Kevin R tau
Maya
the singer Vishnu and Kadesh adam square
ski Susan D Ward Douglas H Smith also
master of science
ho Chung woo Elizabeth a
stop Julie a yang sir journal tanoto
Richard Lu Nikolas L side Zakia arse
siruni mark a Venini Master science and
materials engineering Rizwan Andrew
severe on Hal Velazquez master science
and metallurgy John E Matt's career L
villa master science in polymers Mark V
bull hard
Douglas G Walker master signs the
material science and engineering Michael
W Daniels Daniel Wolfensohn Julius II
Duncan chick young 1 John 4 Natsu
Henry s woo let's see who gainin Ming
Wei be woo he called Danielle be Lazo
Lynette see ye the following students
among the first to receive the master of
engineering degree at MIT master of
engineering and electrical engineering
computer science Christine as Chow
Vikram young John Jonathan L Clayman
Maria Elizabeth Zapata
King honk on Bachelor of Science as
recommended by the Department of
Mechanical Engineering Andrew I a
certain Gabrielle M Owen Carlos I Duran
gari
a Rao Patricia a foot every R inverse
Ashanti Gaja Veera Master science and
electrical engineering and computer
science Francisco Aguirre the third Amy
s Goren marjoram alladhina Chad be
gunlogson Philip Al Bayda Richard G
Hanson jr. Jonathan W Bab
Paul H Saul Jonathan deep
[ __ ] Makalu David Berman Patrick s ro
Roxanne our Blanchard Richard C side
Timothy J Boyd Armand a villian Carlos
Cabrera mecha dare Alexander C whoo
Emira
e Catawbas Bachelor of Science in
material science and engineering
durian K bulge on a Charney Carroll V
will grow
Andrew ciao Stephen C Britain Andrew H
Cheung Sarah H buta Satyen our court any
be Chang
Tony a Ling Shan see chapping Hong tu
Carl Kay chain Michael D Falcon Geoffrey
a the wolf Irene Fung shanty dong Andrew
s Gavin Laura l Ellsberg Newton Gupta
Joshua a federally David T how she'll
poppy got Corey
Timothy J Hazen same be Goucher Terrence
taeho
David Gomez James C ho libs Elizabeth
Gonzales Judy L house David W got Oh
Kyle K ey Monica L Gupta Brian are
Jacobson and s hirahara a lyric Zehra
Java Harry Julia Jay Wong Frank s Kim
Jon why tang Bridget L push narrows
Barbara M Kennedy would nan H law ye
Mary Beth kosu way sing Lee
Doris L Li Nicole s love sung be Li
conlou Yolanda a Leung Stephen W Lin
Rafael Levin also master of science
Louis see Mars the third John W Lum or
dead Marin Andrew see McGeorge and Rick
Martin Glenn see na VIU's Calderon no LS
Massey Barbara M Nichols Mike okay
McCandless Catherine a Oldham Laura
Eamon dice Sean F Peterson Hagen and
Jane a stove Timothy L Rowley whom are
in jail
Wendy see Russell Christine a order Oh
Serena a sax Clarabelle G patio an on a
set lor Lolita Parameshwar on Pamela C
Street Brian M Poirot Tommy T Thomas
Alexander Pfeifer Kota way no Ryan J
rested David my sperg value L rich I
Yamamoto aunty Salcedo killin k yang
member of the class of 1994 executive
committee Irish our bachelor of science
as recommended by the Department of
material science and engineering
Bradley J Begley enric a RCR car
Bachelor of Science in electrical
science and engineering
Tracy e Adams chin we'pon Charu L odd
laka Gary J tarnowska Claude K Amedeo
Neal H tender Raj Ian Amir taja mark see
torrents Satoshi
asari also master of engineering she has
C Venkatesh Trevor J Bower also master
of engineering Joseph E walled the third
Michael G Beck Ron wife Carmen s
Bellavia Holly a Yenko Dirk em burn old
also master of science Ji Hoon yup
Thomas B Chadwick jr. also Master of
Science in easier ed Upanishad k
Chakrabarti Master of Science in
chemical engineering Peter a boot off
William cage and member of the class of
1994 executive committee Master of
Science in chemical engineering practice
Glenn our Bolton Victor e chin Jane F
CBN Amy s chain he means thing
Susan a qu juts Nadia David K ciao
Andre Ellison Henry II Chung also
masters of engineering Joshua Levinson
Christopher a cook also master of
science Theodorus G mija polis Matthew L
doll also master of science Anita F
Parkinson Daniel C daily also master of
science he and Michael Kay Daly Nancy J
Zoeller David M DiCaprio Master of
Science in ocean engineering David s
Barrett
I recede entin 2/3 also master of
science David J Chen guvo widest I also
master of engineering mark a hey nurse
Jeffrey C Dickerson Manoj be Keshav on
Andrew H Dixon also master of science
Karen M labogen ski Nolan J Duffin
master science naval architecture marine
engineering Liana M Alvarez Lopez our
turtle Facundo also Master of Science
master science in naval architecture
marine engineering naval construction
and engineering Marcus our Heath one
Ferrara Rangga also master of science
kick Odie a chip of Samuel J Freiburg
Patrick a little Daniel our Freedman
grant be Thornton John M datura also
master of engineering Master science
notion systems and management Robert E
Burke Peter a Garbus also master of
science Christoph pizzette Roy garbage
also master of engineering gaeseong
Roger she goes master of science and
Aeronautics and Astronautics Pamela s
Barry Marcus Allen Gilbert Sean L board
Rosalie J Gonzales Patrick a cathode
mark s grazinsky Joon Choi Daniel F Ghul
Diego s Diaz Robert P ha Fabian Fadi da
David L Harris also master of
engineering Katherine a Fritz Eric our
height Raja and glaze 14 a share John J
glue shik Lester e where e AO h go young
J M also master of science
Margaret II Grimaldi Laroy s Jackson the
third Simon see grow cut Christopher B
Jalbert Thomas P gross
Michelle see Jen Ryan and L Kansa / /
joy P Hockaday Courtney and Laban
Timothy E calve itís also master of
science
Kenton are leaks out Eleni kappa john is
also master of engineering victor all
award
hisham i Kasab also Master of Science
Michael as public Muhammad J Khan Stacey
M priest he why Kim
Amy R Pritchett Jonathan J clarin also
master of science John Robinson the
third Gretchen e-coat Keith Rogers
Timothy n Kucha also master of
engineering Raymond Jay Sedwick Samuel
m1 also master of science gin seat and
we lean Michael Tiffany DS g hengly also
master of science
Lisi young JH Lee master science and
nuclear engineering Anthony L Brinkley
ken w Lee also master of science
Cynthia EFT wrong Kenneth S Lee also
master of science Matthew a fairy mark M
Lee also master of science
Michael a golden Wang Lee also master of
engineering
Ruxandra P Golan sq Desmond our Lim
chang-jung Margaret a course on coal ye
limb Rana Lee John W Lynn Matthew P
should see
Henry why Lou Aaron Angie trust man
David Aslam Master Science and
Technology and policy
Jason F a morale Sri joy mahapatra
Robert B Atchison Paul L Mangione also
master of science
Monica M Becker Allison M Moreno also
master of science
Judith be coddled Scott a McDermott also
master of engineering challenge Kent
Veneman been borough 15 and Cornell's
Michael s Mermelstein Jeffrey S Goldman
Chad H Mickelson Lewis a Gomez Ugarte
Garcia Carlos muñoz Lindsay a Oakland
Susanne M Murphy
Thomas Wiley he sucked numb 1p Montero
didn't win noon Anthony P Stark
Christopher C Nisan Takeshi Sugiyama
Francis d yay Stephen C pal Shaun T
Nolan Robert a tailor or on for me a
Olli g'day
Jhansi Weiss Edward J roulette master of
science and transportation Ruth and
Monsignor for shewn our hotel also
master of science
David s tough bird Saladin K Patterson
oke Nobu Hut's guy Brian T Pendleton
Geoffrey K murasa mark a Rosa michael s
ramming David L Samuel said I Yuki yogi
do it see Seward the fourth battle
master of science
master of science without specification
of field Jonathan brief cone Philip shoe
you and her
Daphne why she George s Higdon
Christopher M Smith Heisler young Chui
see Wong Shrieker Serena Manuel II Jaime
Esqueda Jennifer why son
Lily Lim Rajesh
Surya Devaraj ming lou o h ton Thomas
you Himmler track D Tran also master of
science electrical engineer Laurieann
Belle Castro Manish k to taya also
master of science
Vishal L Bhagwati Praveen a vizier
awning ocean engineer George's Mardan
jealous Scott are velázquez also master
of science
Gregory Osborn Shashi Kumar venkataraman
naval engineer naval construction
engineering mark D break Oh Scott see
Vickers Francis are Kohlberg Lawrence T
wine David M Fox Stanley si lang Rodrick
M listed David s Warren Steven P Marco
Michael C Webber John see ORS alley
Jennifer a Welch Melissa see Smoot Brian
F Williams Gregory R Thomas Diana F Wong
also master of engineering nuclear
engineer Mahmoud a Chima owner whoo also
master of science Doctor of Science with
all the rights and privileges pertaining
thereto
George V abou schleede Dennis W yarn
jia qian Jang su Paul - no ski i Chuck
so also master of science
Maureen teef a bachelor of science and
electrical engineering and computer
science Christina J Gibb hisham a Hassan
I'm Alvin T lamb bevelle Heslov Hugh be
Morgan Besser yacht SEC jock nur Raul T
Rao John as king
Kuang Yi ton your jaws margaritas
bachelor of science and computer science
and engineering Sudan Chi M Agarwal also
master of science one and pastrana
Nascimento ali allah be also master of
engineering Liu Chang Ching Danielle M
albro Michael D Richard al-karim
s rakia Mach inside L David R Bakr Eric
J Shepherd Tony Jay Bacigalupi Alexander
s Justine ski Philip W Barker Rahul
Singh V Charles H berry Steven P Smith
Alfredo
embosses also master of science
Christopher W Swan Matthew H Burkle's
also master of science Kimo white am
nathaniel our bogan also master of
engineering
vasin Venugopal n Scott D centorrino dr.
philosophy with all the rights and
privileges pertaining thereto
Eric H Anderson Chi p-chan
also master of engineering and Rui Aires
euro L chen-wong kbecque Bernard Chen
Lakshmi Canton Bala Subramaniam gin s
Choi Daniel F Baldwin John why
ciao Daniel G Baltus say hi cha Abdul I
Baraka shirt Chung also master of
science John W Baris
Kimani P Clark Karen Bergman
Daniel n core also master of science
sir Roth cabu Nia Jason s Corneille also
master of engineering Gary H Blackwood
Christopher G cotton also master of
engineering Theodore sea-bottom or
Albert G Coulson the third Allen C brick
conan be daily some w cha Todd Oh
Dampier Brent V chambers
Michael B Davidson Ronald D Cheney Amit
V Desai you Chandi Chang Matthew L don't
Jimmy k10 William J early take' Chang
David E
Evans also master of science Wooyoung
toy Harris L Gilliam John Dee Chung
yevgenii Goodrich Joseph a curtsy
George I [ __ ] Yanis Simon a Collins
William II elfin Stein Kenneth M cross
wait Daniel J Hill Kevin M Cuomo
Frank y ho also master of engineering
Nancy a dolly
Karen w ho Nathan Jade Olsen
yup ho also master of engineering ding
ding
Shaun T ha godís John elder ant
Christopher a Horton also master of
engineering Ellen M ID
mark P Hearst Leon Fong
Patrick H Jefferson Jace's favela Andrew
J cos Matthew our full nur Kevin seek
enabler
Daniel a frost Michael Jacob Fortran Gao
Yuval Koren Michael golf fob Denise kung
also master of science
Robert Pete Gormley William K Lee ira
jay heimer wits William Lynn Helen and
hon David a lippy also master of science
oma a Hassan Bryan s litovsky Barbara D
haze Yan vilem Matson also master of
engineering Scott the Hector David a
mouse also master of science
hi Herbert Damon a McCormack Roderick T
Hinman Frank Meng who reached be polish
offski Jin yow Valdemar P Horwitz Arthur
W min Thomas C shoe
Thomas P Minkoff jang-soo who
Christopher M Montgomery Stephen G
koushik Douglas H Muir James M
Hutchinson Michael L Murtagh Deborah Jay
Wong Radhika Nagpal also master of
science
ah da je says Vasquez Jonathan a Olynyk
Hammett ishik David s Park Robin and
Jake's Renee X para your honor
Jung gargy a Patel Lolita je t'ai go car
Nicholas J Pia Lee as Johnson
Susan Daisy Booga Monica al-kahf re
Susan K race T Nabil Iike Holly
Jeffrey B Reebok Gibran and Karim Scott
t Rickard jr. also master of science
Andrew Ankara Nicholas Jeremy D Rishel
someone Kaushik Alexander D Rosen
Mathias cough Christine see shy haleh's
Peter Kofi Naz Shah here are Sal yawning
Steve a Kramer
Benjamin D soon Arvind Kumar James our
Chi jr. a shock V Kumar Jang hoon shoe
Pratyush Kumar Roy Seto also master of
engineering Bradley see cosmo syed ahmed
Zi Shan Agatha Telus Khalifa's guru
Sivaraman also master of science chi or
Kaylie Ekrem s-salam is also master of
engineering Jang Hyuk Lee nitesh a suit
shark also master of science young Lily
daiji Takamori Lawrence H Lee Lucy M
Tancredi motion Lee Daniel G - ma'am
Sylvain lay back Kimball D Thurston the
third Chi Kong Lee's Clifford SC also
master of science shall John's lu-david
a tumor yipping Luke mark a or mocker
you ming lou
Tolga II I Susan earth Jose Lopez
Jeffrey our van Dijk Patrick J Lord
Jonathan Weiss
Takashi me Okawa Michael L we see
spyridon a maracas
Robert W Winston Eric are Marsh
Alexander C whoo also master of
engineering Ralph P Mason Chacon a cow
also master of science
Miyajima courage Susan SJ also master of
engineering Daniel J McCarthy diesel D
you Vincent
M McNeill air hone you on M resume
Robbie for Bachelor of Science in
chemical engineering
William a Arnold John e Meyer Sophia T
Bermudez Heyman Milan far Robert Jay
gray WA Kim dog Ming Kristen a Breslin
Rabia jamesha Lonnie Robert J Casa
daunting John Dee Moore's Mary Ann a
casa burger Bradley a Moran Dennis chain
Mohsen mostly ethan i chen xiu shot
Nadine Elton M chin all F Neely Helen
Troy cross Amir Pinero John H John John
and when Christopher teach on Peter our
Knuth Karen I chew John H oats Michael K
young David R Otis jr. Vivian MD Xango
Tita
Marius Christos pop IFC meal give it a
Drayton Linney Parker
visca s diverse than Matthew hpower
Sandra C L Tringham member of the class
of 1994 Executive Committee
Timothy s Quinn Sammy J Farah Libya em
rats
Elsa our Flores mark be Reinhold Jeffrey
a galvan jiren Jonathan D gasps young
dong
Efren susana be George David see Rick's
Anastasio see Jana caucus and if the
wrote junghwa a Jim Widow Desalle gucci
Rafael Gonzalez jr. Karen be cirrhotic
Jason a Gretzky Ali Shah JEE Julie Jae
hun Scott a Sikorsky Kirk our hill
Lewisham Silvera catching d ho je n'aime
Simmons Matthew be hauled him OSHA says
Smith and Dorothy mg or sung song
Colleen V angle is Ian Ronald L Spangler
jr. cristela L Jones Darian and three
Batson Jeanette J cow Bethany J Stadler
Daphne Caritas one Brian severe on a
Villanova John L clap ice Jean and
Sullivan Takashi e Komatsu young and tan
Yoko condo you Yin tang ana i la plaza
mohammed a kazoo G Ernest s yang ricardo
téllez chef Sookie Christine
Lynne chrysanthus DITA Williger Michelle
knew Johannes H tyson heather L lucky KD
Thompson Richard C McKern member of the
class of 1994 executive committee Thomas
M tool
Nilesh H Mahan dolly
whoo-haw w sang shil P Mara Chi wat Tsui
David T oil Seamus t2 e now co Munakata
Franklin a turbek Kirk T Noda John a
Reuben the Judy see pang marked Eve and
award
nitesh parasurama Murat Eve a solo
Susan why Park geun-hye Wang Chandra
Patel David P Williamson Jacob e
pecheneg John W with singer and Nicole n
Pellegrini Joyce Y Juan Jose E
pareo William G Worley Eduardo Jay Paris
Albert em young Mary Ellen Pothier can
be seized zangi muhannad m KU by
charming Zhang Jason M reaches Sehun
zone Maribel Rodriguez de la Torre Ali
aims of fog re roii Rodriguez
advanced degree diplomas will now be
presented to students in the School of
Humanities and social science have
completed the specified degree
requirements
Master of Science in political science
Nancy J Cohen Daniel G sabotage
Christine II Denver Jason see Shenzi dr.
philosophy with all the rights and
privileges pertaining thereto
Gustavo II canyon arrow michael j
schlosser carol be Conaway RT Shukla
Martina Koppelman menachem b3 chai guy
LD been Lauren W theis Maura P Doyle
Maya a klutz
John a Hassler Patricia I tau Douglas a
Jones Julia el hotel Ruth a Judson Susan
a Weakland Peter L klebanov Randolph e
West Owen a Lamont John our Westland
Shanley Susan K Wang Wei Li why Tong
Wong Donald P B Marin jr. Bachelor of
Science as recommended by the Department
of Chemical Engineering Vijay K Lottie
Jeffrey C McConnell Richard Lee Andrew P
Morris
Savita a Moen Michael P O'Malley
Christopher T singly Elizabeth H
prodromal gh yo Neil J Rappaport
Bachelor of Science in ocean engineering
Inigo J Puente
James II shock bachelor of science and
Aeronautics and Astronautics Christopher
and Schneider Ryan L Blanchett Antonio
steal embezzle David M Bren Robert J
Staton Tammy L sagon
Alejandro M Verner Mario J compost Aaron
s yellow it's joon-hee Troy advance to
be diplomas will now be presented to
students in the Sloan School of
Management
who have completed the specified degree
requirements master of science and
management
Thomas e a bell Lisa II Cullen I an H
atom Daniel J Corcoran the third Riaz h
ad Jimmy Sonia and Senate Betsy being
Adams Kevin Egan LaLanne our arena
Christine J parada a meet our go wall
Kendra J party Abdul Razak al-qasim
Darrell our Hemingway amid SL Noemi
Heather L powered Eddie
Alon John her mark our Anderson John M
Kerwin Robert L Armacost Junior Eric M
Klein John Michell Osterley Attila Jerry
Len Joe and jealous e FN so fullest
Molly V Lucas Thomas Kane Atkinson Duane
a Ludwig Antoinette K that's Eva James P
Mahoney William K Alette a Lawrence K
McGovern Fernando a Vanessa Nicole L
Mitchell try a Bailey Christine L
Montgomery Moya Vaadin Andrew be more
Amy see Blake
Enrique Morales eatery no James a bonus
Shannon Moynihan Banu Bhaskar
John L Muir
Paul M Brenner wrong V New England's
p.m. Brooke
Chad J : Sean eat brown Jeffrey C Olsen
jr. Bernard
e / sack John Paul and Olynyk michael s
Callahan Frank J Pell covert the third
onion chopped
Michael S Phillips Steven our Chaffin s
Luca pitenin also master of science
Julie Chang Tony and Pyrrha michael e
Charles
Becky e Raymer Paul D surrett Melanie s
rich sign on table Mary be Richards suwa
s Chang
Matthew are Matthew H Robinson June Troy
Robert see Rosenfeld
Jill a Christians Rahul a Saha Victorio
M Corbeau Tara and Schiavone wenton pea
coat a Michael a man ski Karen s
Crandall Lawrence s Schwartz William W
Crandall jr. Julian cell Russell D
Crawford Randy s Stevens yon H curry
Ernest J ticket the third Luca DeAngelo
Allen P Thomas Joseph F to change
Sanjay s rakia L&D DeVoe anna-lysa
l Vigo Patricio jdi's Steven Wong the
seal Diaz de Banja Melissa M right
Cheryl M Duckworth Michelle Avada Paul W
dumb
Willie s sieminski Dale a do tile
Bachelor of Science in nuclear
engineering laughs ug r know also master
of science
Brian G Eagle tomorrow a Galen Albert
aid Eliason Nicole a Larry er Agusta
Elmer the fourth Nicholas B Leavitt
Gerald L and verso van de w Merriman
John M Eustace Rodrigo our Ruby on Oh
also master of science
Frank X Fang Raul Valdes Jason our
Ferris eric s fears Bachelor of Science
diplomas will now be presented to
students in the School of Humanities and
social science who have completed the
specified degree requirements bachelor
of science and economics Melanie al-bab
gone deep Fitzgerald
Igor our business William G Fontaine
Eileen L Brooks
Celia am Francis in Sokcho Catherine II
fret arc and jelly
now Luke Cho Eric J Freiburg Marjorie J
Krista yasujiro food uka water keep to
see Gilfillan J and Gardner John see
Hanson Michael Teague carska Joshua
Hartman Edward W Gaskin Jr Kevin and
Hetherington Kathleen a Gavin Jennifer H
food Supriyo gosh / e you come for
Joseph and Gleason David J Kessler Nisa
Goldstein Christopher age Kim
Timothy J Grenier Cujo Lou mark Pete
Grossman
Colin beam McKee ragu guru-murthy George
mano Crusoe's Robert seed Gustafson
nithya nagarajan oh hey L Guterres
hard-on Oh Jefferson
D Hamlin jr. Frank see Pope jr. Joey Chi
Harada Giovanna Sardi Edward J Hoagland
jr g ho song yen's
hub Steven P Wiggins Robert S Hakeem Ian
jr. Jill am Woodward's James F Higgins
jr. Bachelor of Science in political
science
Allison Gilchrist PD nori kira bataki
Matthew H Hersh Daniel J Holmes Lee
alien Nima T Hawk Brooks even though
Elizabeth see her on Benjamin Jared
Reneau John F porridge Michael J
Saltzman John P Houston Isabel h1g swing
- Steven T was lost key William H
Hughes the third Bachelor of Science in
anthropology archaeology Melinda T
Berman anja be Hummel Bachelor of
Science in music Paul Blair indeed Bach
host the third reno Ihram injure Nathan
M Burt Hiroshi Ishii gig Bachelor of
Science in writing to these d Bushman
Boris Z Ivanovich Albert T Kim Todd R
Jackson
Cecilia M Oh
Scott K Jacobs Meyer Lloyd Oh Rodriguez
Olsen bevel G Jones bachelor of science
and humanities Robert Jade icland
Brent W Jones francium Elizondo smell
Keys mark R Jones harmony s Harrison
Peters bouquet Coahoma young Rebecca
widom Samuel ha Swan bachelor of science
and humanities and engineering LeAnn see
Clark Patrick M cofer Bachelor of
Science in humanities and science mark D
Bachman Kiba ken de Wong yang Qi Yi
Silla a curse bomb Eleni see de janice
michael see Kim Alfred H eaten the third
then in Kimball wet skin bomb Kristin K
nu murderer Douglas a Kirby
Mary Beth e Rhodes Philip Kirk slick
nerve nog meg so Robbie
Michael F curse Craig C West
David beat platter Heather C Williams
syndrome hiatal Kojima Bachelor of
Science in philosophy
Mildred F Wong Utica condo Bachelor of
Science in science technology and
society Jennifer Jay Lee James he
kuehnemund Bachelor of Science diplomas
will now be presented to students in the
Sloan School of Management who have
completed the specified degree
requirements Bachelor of Science and
management science awesome yabba dear
Roberta L coalition Sun ready and
muchacha Jason ku coke Kuan chime Makoto
Kubota engineer Chanda Romany Kevin beat
Kurt slur Philip why chin Junko lammed
Brian Chet Rome Douglas W lamb
a chi elisandra Lauria Bernard why chin
Peter W Latham Celeste V Chung member of
the class of 1994 executive committee
Stefan M Lawson Heiser peak young K Chun
Edward M leave Jeffrey M do so kwang-ho
Lee Jonathan adran Monica Lee Hellena H
gang Veronica Jamie ginger J Hansen
yen's
e legally Andrew T Henshaw Trond e line
Deana L Hiltner Erin Jay Levine Michelle
D shoe
Mitchell D Lee V Franklin s conch Robert
W Lewis Lillian W quo egg Lim Majak vol
speak Pauline why do McCormack Elizabeth
H leon lewis a jános frederick while of
gustavo a lopez Padilla Amanda L Morin
Thomas see Luke Christina
ish Scott see McDonald Gen Y nip Zander
H Mack Christopher J Oh Michelle ain't
Macquarie very wrong
Juan Carlos Maldonado Francis empanado
1p Martic no name mercury dress ropal
mark be Martin son he d1 Kathy Ann
martín de leekie Terry Wong Oh ACO
Martinez Bachelor of Science diplomas
will now be presented to students in the
school of science who have completed the
specified degree requirements Bachelor
of Science in chemistry
Joseph K a BT helix Matteo Marini
Anderson have ROM G mayhem
Carmen M Barnes Giovanni a Missoula
Marquis Bejarano Jon F McCaffrey John J
bluesy the third Geoffrey a McCarthy
felony Cargill Jamie D McCourt JP Chang
John Dee McAvoy Todd t fully theater or
D McNiff David B Gordon Christina W
MacNeil Jason our Greenwald Stephan see
may host kimberly s Hamad Eduardo Melo
Gonzalez Maki inada James C Meng
Canisius clothed
b-2s men on Elizabeth be Kuchar Winsky
Paula a Michelle Amelia m la pena Daniel
P miles just H Lee Byrd mark Manoj John
J led with Thomas L Monroe Augustine Jay
Lee rod on Kate Northey Pauline
Elia Bernard matey the NW Lindsay Steven
M naggy REM Lipsky
Koishi Nakajima annalisa ma renew aid
nella cherry Samuel T muddler
Yoshihiro Namur on Elizabeth s Nessler
may F Ness Rolla JA Quincy Niles I
reached Neela Condon ons P Olsen the
fourth Randall T nickel James quirk RT
Road Nicole I have skied Jennifer
gesture shil para meant a nice egg or
insane Alice saw
Stephen M Nova coat Thomas II will help
Ivan and Novikov Donald M Williams G
Jonathan Jonathan are otoko Bachelor of
Science in biology
Bloomberg Ahmad Chiharu oka Paul a
Alfaro Aoki Okumura Java em up felt less
do Candia Clarence be Applegate e a
Oliver Steve s Bay
this way
Irene a Bonnie ei Oliver Jason B Bach
Lawrence our Oliver Julianna L buck Ken
Oh Maura Karen why Chang June H we jus
DC Chen Jien G Oh sue me Elaine watchin
Geoffrey Oh Gregory why chin Robert D
over B John a qu Philip s Powell
Julie why Choi Ryan Kate parks Lisa Chow
Sean P Patterson Angela W Choi Anna
em-pod Roth Marcos JR lim chu Ming pping
Jackie see Chun Fernando Perez Hickman
grant K Iceland Michael L Peterson would
EJ Francis Mark J pepper L&M gonzalez
Keith T pig Pierre s ho Richard a
pycelle Sara M how mark our hot club
Elaine wha gwaan Francis pond sneak
Zeeshan s for same tree ID Prague of
bone Jill each ours rice M well Devon
Cantus area follow our rabello when Kong
L go
Melissa a the phony genteel M Michael a
Rafferty Veronica eek Lepus Coca Raju K
raju bobby s corn
guru-murthy ravi shankar George M Koontz
jr. james ii read young tequan Carolyn W
Ren Deena Jay Lim Margaret M Reynolds
Wing Chun live
who Ronnie rua tena Verdi our kumara
Liyanage Pedro a Richards Reynold I
Lopez solar Robert T the sock on Gregory
am loo Benecke James F Robbins joy s
Miyashiro Thomas key role of Turkey NT
new one Tanya J Romanoff Helen jay Park
Bernanke roses unum Park
Richard D Rosson Tammy a porter Jordan D
Reuben sin' Melissa a Rivera Marco sake
Cuomo Laura a Rubenstein Andy and sack
Eugene F sister junior ma sayuki Saito
surgery D Scripture Adams Maria s
Sakamoto John M sub L John H sandbag
David Q she be named Sonny
Julius song Brian K shank Rebecca else
parks Andrew G Snyder Christopher our
Springer Peter H Sumire Michelle a
star's vocal Sumire yes Christopher
stroke Jonathan B Schwartz Jenks Suman
Omar sec and the e son Todd a Santeria
Eileen s son Susan C shackford Valerie
p10 Shahab Seidman and so shall eat soup
lon John H friend Newton the fourth mark
Slater
BAM bang so captain zoom I'm Stephen D
Spencer Jim s whoa Kevin P Stein young
do a Robert B Steinberg Bachelor of
Science is recommended by the Department
of Biology J Michael and Driessen Pedro
a suazo ELISA J Dugan Albert sushi Amy I
sue
Sanjay 20 Tracy and Keith Julia K cider
Jeffrey G Strickland he'd a Yuki
Takashi Bachelor of Science in physics
al-fatiha savage truce Ryo takahashi
Raphael Behar noburo Tamura jonathan see
Bierce cheeky on ten Gunther L Brenes
when y 10 Victoria II Carlton Yiping 10
Jennifer Carson mark T Terry beth el jem
Gregory J Tobin wipe Chen Jennifer E to
me
Laura Leigh Cook also master of science
guild Tran eunhaeng Cramer's Matthew D
true vaping Richard H downy mark s
trickling nice shot Esther Gavi takuji
to kimoto Ezra G or John dieter Bethy
Joshua Ehrlich yes you o UT yama Albert
s Fisher Vinson be van de Becque Roger s
flugel Garret J van sale
Nathan W Frazier Jessica M Wagner Daniel
I Goldman charlie je Wang
Marshall Gordon Robert Dean ward
Helene D Grogan hero nori what a save
William seed gum Andhra s Weisberg David
s hails throwing a went david h hitori
de ser gol vernik filo Elliott ekwa
Clarence G Williams jr. Philip be Hume
Jeffrey S Williams Mario a human is
karate
Kerry Elwood Daniel cats James Wong
David s Kern Timothy M would s Darren
kid Ian Stacy why whoo Andrew R curve Z
Akiko Yabuki Richard R Lester jr. large
on yaqoob' Peter H mal chin few yang
Christopher arm Indus Pablos yo analyst
REM Mizell Maki
Yoshida James II Morris Christian H
young Assad eggnog V Jews ow
Erickson Erlich ye do Kristi is Nelson
Master of Science in management of
Technology Darryl a Aberdeen Adam Norman
Alberto Agostini Vika Nystrom ElBaradei
Alfonso Quran yo Hana
Okoye Ellen F Amy they hold the patel
Toshi Harold
yoki Jonathan D Pelle
Russell J callo Michael J person Roberto
Surma Nene
Jeremy s v [ __ ] Alberto de la Rosa James
W Reiner Rajiv s decide Vincent D
David B diamond Alexandra ero taro
Anders T Fernanda Victoria a Charbel
Julio Jill s Farian
David L Sisson Hazuki
Harada Daniel V Smith Christopher Jane
Hara no Robert P st. Pierre guy T hatch
Susan so Joe no Mary Jane Hellyer
David II Tang ma Satoshi Kon Oh Bridget
Italian Shalom Koppelman Eric s 10
Torelli Dennis E Malone Kent are Thurber
Pietro moncada paternal Costello Shana
am Tribbiani
Yukio nakamori Wang Yusuf one more CD
Lucille no Dan Craig C Walker Hideki
Okajima Joshua and win also master of
science Vittorio a Pareto Bachelor of
Science in cognitive science
Patrick see Andrew Carl W Pistorius
Emily J blood wallow
ephra Delhi James C Cavanaugh incense a
Sanchez Philip as child a goostin Silva
castaño Lee Ann Collins Florence
Sybil Nikolas L Kelvin Peter turns
Hokkien Adam T Lindsay Ellen R prepster
Jacob W Loomis jacksie Tucker jr.
komotini Gong Benjamin and VanFleet Kira
Raphael Edith V on e Velasco Evelyn F
Smith Jeffrey and perfume
Samuel Shaw Street Master of Science in
operations research sums you on Adam L
Taylor Sarah Murthy Gopala Krishna
Bachelor of Science and Earth
atmospheric and Planetary Sciences Kyle
W blouse also master of science new king
q mark our brand earth
Kamala Pete murti Janet G Chen militates
a Stan Polk's Poulos Christy M Hubert
Christian H voigtländer Steven RJ Doctor
of Philosophy with all the rights and
privileges pertaining thereto sharm el
Shabab ur robert f powers to 4th Aaron
out M icky bone IDs straighter also
master of science
Peter Claussen Bachelor of Science and
Mathematics Christopher a Adler
Patricia Robinson David s Alexander now
leak at the bag sense head Patrick
Tuohey Baker advanced degree diplomas
will now be presented to students in the
world's premier school of science we
have completed the specified degree
requirements Master of Science and
physics
James C last oath salvina and the Verena
de Zarate Lorenzo T corn Alba Bradley J
Boulevard Doctor of Philosophy with all
the rights and privileges pertaining
thereto
Roy D Adams unka M Brad Thomas W ocular
Paul J boot kovitch James be Applegate
Nikolas L kassimatis Dan Arnon hmmm
sulla Billy r8n vomit Adrian peaches
Gregory J Patel the NK Clemens Keith the
buyer
Justin J Corvino Louis M before Terry L
do Yan Shannon s Blanchard mark a
Erickson Amanda s Bosch Alexander gam
board sheriff m ba pros
Wilfred graves jr. Bronwyn M Brown
Samuel D gross Richard C Carter
Maloney a ha hee Jun che William J
Hartnett Chang Chang Chang Todd a hey
Ming yo Chang Cynthia L Hayward Dimitri
be lofty
Bobby Joe Hutchinson Thomas the fiancée
olam Carl Hudson Locker
John H come KTB joint Andrew our cook
Becca acre onon the weeks
r-truth Cruz Yura Kim Patricia a cult in
Dario jailer Matthew W Davis Howard J
Lou gyeonggido mare Elizabeth I'm Adam
Don angong JSONP Murkowski when G dog
Benjamin M Moskowitz Marla L Dowell
Anthony J Mullen Eduardo the Estevez
Scott T Parcells barber K Farhan Andrew
preczewski Chang Feng Monica L Ren
injure Sondra a Fela Jason M robando
Harold age spots Clara Sanchez
Carl be frisbee Shelly are sure James P
Gardner jr. Matthias DC blur
Timothy J Gardner an EOB so my OG the
annual M Jia Quinta Daniel East I'm
Ellen R Goldman Richard son
Megan e greather Desmond and Surrey Paul
II gonna Jenice Oswald Anna L Helgeson
Marcin Oh shoo Murr Gabor [ __ ] William W
Tucker Matthew J Holman Teresa K you
long shoe
Robert J's go Nina una Huang Bachelor of
Science in mathematics with computer
science
[Applause]
[Music]
olafemi G Anthony Pierre FB blaze John a
Baroni boob nosh Jane
Michelle and Chama shocked Michael a
Joffe Kara s angle
Susan thei Johnson and a Essen John
alkane Junior Andrew see goldish saw las
casas je hang quits John J Kim pandita
Georgia say chin Kim Robert Lao
Catherine a Kirkpatrick Duane ill
Lawrence David T Kirkpatrick aime je
Madison Alvin Couric Stacy McGee ver
Kevin J League sorry Stacy Jennifer and
more Philip Seymour Connell safer
Gary F Marcus nikunj see OSA Pietro met
Sony Anthony s Rivera mark our Metzger
re Trachtenberg Rachel e Myers mark
Beata Nelson
Wesley why Miyazaki Joseph W was Erick
jock Joyce see moral Randall T Whitman
David P Morrison annecy whoa
- and Nagoya d-m be oral me how or
quiche Neil J Perlmutter Chen bin ping
John D Perkins Peter M pill
Peter J Rothschild Stephen G Raleigh the
second Greg a Schultz Jhanvi ceiling
Jeremy be selling gun mark are sipping
ski Darren a Sherman mark a Smith Ron a
Souls
David why son Ben Watson Jacque Hiroaki
sugah Paul sucio no Theodor W son
Alexander a Szabo
Ching hua 10 G town can beat a or in
Kempton kyon be Theo
James M Turner Geordi Naveed ow
Louis a bi nueva hazus no no alas yes
senior Margaret L Wenberg the T naught R
Winkler Michael Oh wolf
David W right three shoes
John Z Y n Michael J you eat ah aid you
chou-heung you
shot on you Daniel s Zachary Xiao yang
yang renews yang Xiao min
Yao the Woods Hole Oceanographic
Institution and the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology offered joint
programs of education and research in
oceanography and applied ocean science
and engineering dr. John W Farrington
Dean of Graduate Studies at the Woods
Hole Oceanographic Institution is here
it is to participate with Provost riding
in awarding the following joint degrees
Master of Science and mechanical
engineering
Edward our snow Master of Science and
oceanography Lindley Master of Science
in oceanographic engineering hey Hwang
Robert W Keith Brian J Sperry
doctor of philosophy with all the rights
and privileges pertaining thereto
Molly Oh bérenger Joseph a bond Eric
Christopher our Bradley Gail L
christeson Francis see felizardo Cecily
Morrison we've charged a Pavlovic
lipping Wang Susan II way fools
Cecily J wolf
this is the moment we've been waiting
for advanced degree diplomas will now be
presented to students in the Whitaker
College of Health Sciences and
Technology who have completed the
specified degree requirements Master of
Science in toxicology Victoria L F
Shannon
Hilary a :
doctor philosophy with all the rights
and privileges pertaining thereto
karati L chillin Kathleen M Donohue
Bernard M fine
Leon M best parens
[Music]
idle em ballot toned chin
Daniel pay Sonic's
[Applause]
Daniel k3 bird
[Applause]
I speak now particularly to members of
the class of 1944 who were part of the
procession and they were sitting here to
the left of the stage in accordance with
our traditions members of the 50th
reunion class are participating in the
ceremonies this class the class of 1944
entered the Institute before the United
States entered World War two and may
have had the expectation not held by
later wartime classes of a normal
completion of their undergraduate
degrees for most members of the class of
1944 this was not to be the records of
the Institute indicate that of all the
wartime classes at MIT the class of 1944
may well have experienced the greatest
disruption most who entered with this
class did not receive their diplomas
until after the war if at all many did
not return from the war today as you
return to Tech for your 50th reunion we
extend a special welcome to you may your
participation in these commencement
ceremonies recognize and reaffirm your
special place in the history and family
of MIT
it is now my pleasure to introduce mr.
Richard a Jacobs the chief marshal who
will greet the graduates mr. Jacobs is a
member of the class of 1956 and is
currently serving as president of the
MIT Association of alumni and alumnae
thank you dr. gray may 27th is one of
the longest days in the year 14 hours
and 58 minutes dawn-to-dusk
from today's newspaper I do not intend
to make it any longer
let me leave you with one more simple
equation to consider adopt and use in
your continuing quest for knowledge
Lombardi's axiom states the quality of a
person's life is directly proportional
to their commitment to excellence today
you take a major step in that commitment
remember this day look once more around
this great Court it belongs to you
take pride you are a most uncommon group
keep in contact come back off and help
others to achieve what you have
accomplished and will realize later in
life
now join me in the distinguished members
of the 50th and 25th reunion classes of
1944 in 1969 as we applaud today's
graduates and welcome into that most
select company of men and women or mi
t--'s alumni and alumnae thank you
[Applause]
the 128 commencement exercises of the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
are now concluded
[Music]
please join now the backlogs quartet a
splinter group of former logarithms in
singing the school song the stage
assembly and the graduates will please
rise
[Music]
all ye of MIT in loyal
[Music]
love you too Baggins unto me and life is
for Landry
arise and raise your glass and boy
tonight
[Music]
[Music]
gather here once more to be Renard
by I saw
and as we raise our glasses high to
[Music]
those days gone by in praise'
[Music]
we were back again Boylston Street
dressed in my dinky uniform so dapper
and so neat I'm crazy after calculus I
never had enough it was hard to be
dragged away back in the days they were
free from Heron ecology varsity shop
with nothing to do but penalize Aryan
anima metrical top or the
differentiation of the trigonometric
powers the constant pi that made me sigh
in those happy days technology niala
geology o glorious old technology
ecology geology no take me back in a
special frame to that glorious Institute
I learned for the inspiration of the
technological toot I've shown the
quizzical physical prophet chapel and
all that but how I'd love to go again in
a scientific that our technology our
geology o glorious old technology
oh ma yes si si
hese TTS inspi tu tu OTV but see in
general of G my comes after G
[Music]
[Applause]